Germany's Disease Control Agency has
raised its coronavirus risk assessment
to hide the head of the country's Public
Health Institute says stricter measures
are necessary to contain the spread of
the virus that's due to increasing
warning signs from German clinics that
the number of serious cases is rising
all right let's bring in our political
correspondent Hans brunt for the very
latest on this story hi Hans good to see
you so a Germany Center for Disease
Control has raised the risk level now
too high for this coronavirus pandemic
and is warning that strict measures need
to be taken in order to prevent millions
of people from getting infected so what
kind of further measures are meant by
this I think what year the leader of the
Institute was referring to other
measures that we have been reporting
about in the last 24 hours or so in
other words the increased lockdown of
German cities and of Germany as a whole
certain shops do not sell it essential
goods are to be closed and other shops
are restricted in the opening hours
restaurants are restricted in their
opening hours cinemas gyms and all those
kinds of institutions are being closed
down these measures are still to be
implemented in various regions of the
country because the actual measures have
to be decided by Germany's federal
states so they haven't in fact been put
into effect across Germany yet
and in addition of those things that
were announced today by the Foreign
Minister warnings against traveling
anywhere in the world and generally
warnings for people not to travel at all
to stay at home so those are the
measures that are about to be put into
place in addition there are additional
measures to be taken at hospitals
because some hospitals now are getting
to see a large number of serious cases
of coronavirus infection and the
measures that need to be taken they are
to make it possible to treat all of
those additional patients Hans you
mentioned the German Foreign Minister
speaking earlier he's also announced
this 50 million euro operation to bring
home German citizens who are stranded
abroad let's take a listen to what he
said a little bit earlier
the practice elsewhere again the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs has agreed
on a unique program with commercial
airlines which will bring back German
travelers from particularly affected
areas within the next few days we are
talking above all about Morocco the
Dominican Republic the Philippines Egypt
and the Maldives in coordination with us
the airlines will make flights available
for this area the nightstand
alright Hans what are we talking about
here I mean how many people are stuck
and where will they be transferred to we
haven't been given exact figures the
Foreign Minister talked about 5,000
people alone and Morocco's if we reckon
on the other countries that they were
talking about several thousand people
from those countries imagine we could
get to somewhere close to 10,000 people
that will be returning in the next few
days where exactly they will be coming
to here in Germany we don't know yet I
presume that depends on where the
aeroplanes that transport them will land
and possibly on which regions of the
country these visit are these German
tourists come from but it's going to be
a major operation something like this
has never been done by Germany before
Hans we see in countries like Italy
Spain now also France issuing complete
lockdowns of those countries do you
think we could see Germany take a
similar step that would be the last
available measure that Germany still
could impose what's happening at the
moment is of course something similar
but not quite a lockdown not quite the
situation that somebody who goes out on
the streets is to be fined or will be
sent back by the police Germany the
central government would need to impose
a state of emergency to give itself
those kinds of powers and that hasn't
happened yet I think the German
government is hoping that the measures
that have been imposed so far will
finally lead to slowdown in the spread
of the virus and that this last measure
that is still possible a total lockdown
may not be necessary all right our
political correspondent Hans Brent
reporting for us there thank you very
much meanwhile one of the candidates for
the leadership of
Chancellor Angela Merkel's Conservative
Party has tested positive for kovat 19
Swedish math says he only has mild
symptoms and will say at home until the
end of next week the number of confirmed
cases in Germany's approaching 8000
Berlin is not yet imposed a general
lockdown but its Appeals for people to
stay home and avoid unnecessary contact
are having an effect as our political
correspondent Simon Young reports
there's a curious calm in the normally
pulsating heart of Berlin on Tuesday
morning far fewer people than usual were
out and about in the German capital
foreign minister Heiko Maas announced
another unprecedented measure a travel
warning for the entire planet
he said no unnecessary trips should be
made in addition the government will
provide 50 million euros so German
citizens currently abroad can come home
the Ministry of Foreign Affairs has
agreed on a unique programme with
commercial airlines which will bring
back German travelers from particularly
affected areas within the next few days
we are talking above all about Morocco
the Dominican Republic the Philippines
Egypt and the Maldives in coordination
with us the airlines will make flights
available for this area on Monday
drastic steps were announced to beat the
virus shutting many shops
apart from essential businesses such as
food stores and pharmacies civic life is
shutting down schools theatres and
museums are being closed nationwide
Chancellor Merkel asked Germans to stay
at home but strict controls on movement
as in France have not been imposed so
far these measures are unprecedented in
our country they are severe but they are
necessary at this time in order to
reduce the number of personal contacts
which reduces the number of people
falling ill and in turn the number of
severe cases
as even children's playgrounds are
deserted many parents are having to stay
at home to look after their families the
government is offering them extra
support that's best fear for what we're
seeing above all is that many families
are wondering about money they want to
know how to deal with a drop in income
means this is a huge issue it's not a
private matter it needs to be fixed and
the state must help establish a
understood some politicians continue to
search for the right responses to this
rapidly evolving crisis Merkel and the
other EU leaders will come together to
discuss it later on Tuesday by video
link in the US Treasury Secretary
Stephen minuchin will ask Congress to
approve an 850 billion dollar emergency
aid package to protect the economy it's
being reported that these measures
include plans to provide relief to the
US airline industry which has suffered
tens of billions of dollars in losses
due to the pandemic if approved the
stimulus plan would also help small
businesses stay afloat and cut taxes for
millions of American workers alright
let's talk about this story now with tws
financial correspondent jose luis de
Otto is down at Wall Street for us I
Jose good to see you how is Wall Street
reacting to this report so far it seems
that it's still very very early to
celebrate it's been a really choppy
start of the trading session already as
we speak markets are up but only 54
points and they were down 200 points and
at the beginning of the trading session
we were up around 500 points so as you
can see it seems that things could go
wrong very quick here in in the trading
session the bill that is still in in the
Senate hands and it could go up to 850
billion dollars as you point out and may
also include up to fifty billion dollars
to bail out the US airlines it's a still
is still like debated and untie mean is
a key here a lot of Americans live check
to check and unless they receive
immediate assistance and basically cash
as some senators are proposing
they'll probably won't be able to pay
the rain paid their mortgage or even buy
food which I could make a bad situation
even worse also that there is a lot of
talk of why bailing out airlines and not
the full range of industries affected by
the current situations was it beyond
airlines and these tax cuts I mean
looking at the big picture here how
could this bill really help stabilize
what is such a volatile situation on the
markets right now well I think that as I
said before timing timing is key any any
measures and neither to to protect
consumers and a consumer confidence set
to make sure they can survive without
the major disruptions already during the
current situation and also they will
keep some confidence to restart their
lives as usual when when this situation
it's over but but it's going to be very
difficult since economies are already
projecting a contraction of 5% in in the
US economy for the second quarter and
around 80 million jobs are at risk right
now so the goal should be have some some
kind of stimulus already as soon as
possible probably this week because if
by any chance senators go into recess or
leave town there is a chance they could
not be able to return back to DC in in
time for a boat if if things get delayed
Jose you said market started a bit
choppy today yesterday we saw the worst
drop since 1987 I mean give us an idea
what things are like they're down on
Wall Street what our traders saying
traders say here are they at the
exchange here try to keep a smile on
their faces but but they say that these
situation it's uncharted territory they
welcome the monetary stimulus from the
Fed now they are waiting for the fiscal
one from Washington but but they are
clear to say that it is too early to
call a bottom in the stock of market in
the meantime markets are are still open
as you can see the exchange is open but
all of us
need to be checked before entering the
building and the trading floor and in a
worst-case scenario the trading floor
here at The New Yorker Stock Exchange
can fully operate electronically if they
decide to to close it at some point all
right our financial correspondent there
jose luis de Otto
on Wall Street thank you very much
meanwhile researchers in the u.s. have
started testing a potential coronavirus
vaccine on volunteers four of them
received their first injection on Monday
as part of the studies first stage of
human trials the test will see 45
healthy individuals receive to varying
dosages one month apart while scientists
check for side effects and the impact on
their immune systems now even if all
goes well a vaccine is unlikely to be
available for at least one year all
right let's talk about the progress on a
vaccine we can speak to a Christian Lynn
Maya he's a spokesman for the World
Health Organization and he joins us from
Geneva Christian thank you for being
with us here on DW how promising do you
think the talk of a vaccine is at this
stage well thank you good day we are
receiving good news from all around the
world on about 40 different places on
treatments or vaccine progress so any
any news of this direction is great of
course right now but as good as it
sounds and as good as it is
let's hear also that last part of your
message which means by the time we will
have such a vaccine in hand it will take
about a year so with all the great news
we need to focus on today and tomorrow
more than in 365 days ok Christian and
that's what countries are doing they're
imposing partial to complete lockdown
restrictions we're seeing really across
Europe how long will these restrictions
need to be in place
that is a very difficult question it
depends on situation situation of each
of each country as you just reported
about France they have a complete
lockdown which is where I'm calling from
right now right across the border from
Geneva Switzerland Geneva has a
different situation Germany has a
different situation
Poland has so each country is
implementing the best socially to their
knowledge and to the experience and to
the expertise and they will also keep
these measures asbestos and they will
see it well until most likely cases
subside or the curve is spread is going
down let's not forget them one of the
most important parts right now is to
curb this steep rise of cases normally
for the infections as such but because
all of these infected people all those
who need to get care in the hospitals
for my other symptoms or for heavy
symptoms or even need emergency care
they take away space in the hospitals
and which means we do not have space for
so many cases not nowhere in Europe and
other people who have other all any of
the other many many diseases emergencies
accidents we'll have trouble finding
space so this is why it's so important
to curb that that steep rise of cases to
make it flatter to have the health
system be able to cope with drugs and
all patients okay alright so lockdowns
gain as time but Christian are they
enough because we've seen countries like
South Korea be more effective by testing
across the board constantly testing
why shouldn't Europe do the same thing
actually you have a very important point
so this lockdown can only be part of a
comparative approach and the most
important things are three as you just
mentioned test test test
this was repeated yesterday again in the
by the director-general of the World
Health and Information tokenization and
it was it was sent to all governments of
the world testing and following every
single patient and
contacts their possible context is a
most importance and we can only
encourage every government and every
authority as well to do their best to do
these three things test test test
alright we'll have to leave it there
Christian then Maya spokesman for the
World Health Organization thank you for
your insights
Francis joined at neighboring Italy and
Spain in ordering a complete lockdown to
try and halt the spread of corona virus
president Emmanuel macron described this
situation as a public health war the
virus has killed nearly 150 people in
France and infected more than 6,600 as
the clock struck noon in France the
lockdown took effect people must now
carry a document justifying their
reasons for going outdoors only
essential trips and exercise alone are
permitted those who break the rules will
be fined the president has called the
outbreak a war 100,000 police officers
have been deployed across the country
officials stress that everyday life must
be upended to contain the virus to give
you some examples a family lunch dinner
with friends a football game with
friends a game of cards all of that
which might not seem important normally
is now forbidden not only ill-advised
but forbidden each of those meetings
let's not play it down is a moment when
the virus can be transmitted it means
running the risk of speeding the spread
of kovin 19 in the capital Paris an
unusual quiet has taken hold reactions
to the lockdown are mixed I think it's a
bit too strict
you should be able to walk on the
streets if you want people should be to
choose what they want I think it's
necessary it's an epidemic that's
spreading exponentially so it's the
contamination there are many
asymptomatic carriers I could be one of
them the Health Ministry says the
restrictions could be eased in a
fortnight if the virus is sufficiently
contained a straight to to the French
capital then where we join journalists a
Catherine field welcome Catherine tell
us more about people's reactions to this
lockdown well a lot of people are just
taking it on the chin realizing that
they have to be responsible about this
150 checkpoints mostly on the exit to
Paris to check people see whether they
are really going home or they're just
going out to go shopping we've got some
3,000 police patrolling the cattle also
checking to see if everyone knows what's
going on and also just making sure that
shops are closed we've had quite a few
incidents according to the prefect of
police of shops staying open and hoping
that they can at least shift some Goods
get some money in before the big
lockdown comes we've also seen at the
Gare de menthe on us where the larger
railway station store in Paris
a lot of people still fleeing the
capital they're saying that if there's
going to be a lockdown they want to be
in the countryside and police have said
they've got tool this evening to get out
of Paris and then the lockdown will
really come into effect filled and so
how is Frances health infrastructure
coping at the moment mostly in the
region in the east of France is
struggling in those regions the Alsace
and the Moselle alongside the German
border they are really struggling there
were there were big clusters of the
virus there in the early days and we're
hearing both from the prefect of Alsace
and from the Health Department of
Moselle that they are reaching
saturation point and they're just hoping
that that promise that the president
Emmanuel macron made last night when he
said that the army would come into that
region and set up
treat field hospitals but that will come
sooner rather than later because they
really are struggling meanwhile here in
Paris is saying that it's tough but
they're still on top of it but what's
worrying them are the large numbers of
people who are coming in who are younger
than 60 years old a lot of people had
thought this virus only affected order
people but there's a lot of younger
people they say coming in and that is
concerning to them okay so that's that's
the health impact let's talk about the
money
well what's being done to lessen the
economic impact this morning it was
about 45 million euros gonna be put
aside to help companies through this
next couple of weeks and that will mean
giving them money make sure they can
keep operating make sure they can please
staff even though their staff may still
be at home the government's also said
that companies won't have to for the
time being
pay their gas electricity and water
bills the Minister of Finance also said
unfortunately that France will probably
go into recession now but he had some
very comforting words for companies he
said that if need be
France will nationalize firms if it
comes to that and that comes on top of
the big bundle of money only 300 billion
euros that Emmanuel macron the president
said yesterday would be made available
to make sure that the country just
doesn't fall apart economically and both
of them the Minister of Finance and the
president have said the money will be
there don't worry that France sticks
together everyone stays home and nobody
loses their head they say France can get
through this next two weeks i Catherine
the field in Paris thank you thank you
well school to daycare centers around
the world are closing as authorities try
to slow the spread of the coronavirus
workers in certain essential professions
such as medical staff are reporting for
work as more extreme measures are
introduced many parents have been
wondering how to explain the virus to
their children Norwegian Prime Minister
held a special coronavirus briefing only
for children to try and answer their
questions why am I not allowed to
celebrate my birthday
for the other it's because many people
should not be gathered in order to
prevent people from being infected or
you can put a bit extra creative and try
to celebrate via FaceTime or think of
another way to celebrate that you think
is good I think that if someone in the
class has a birthday all the others
should call and sing a birthday song
individually to have something to do so
how should we talk to our children about
this pandemic dr. Anne Herod Rudkin is a
child that clinical psychologists from
the UK University of Southampton and she
consulted on the parenting book what's
my child's thinking welcome to DW doctor
many parents have an instinct to try and
shield their children not just from the
virus but also from all the the bad news
about is that the right approach it
depends really I mean you don't want to
shield them and pretend that nothing is
happening because children are very very
clever and they figure out that things
aren't quite the same as they usually
are but you don't want to overload them
with the too much information either
because children and think about things
differently to adults and they worry
about different things so whereas they
may not need to know that biochemistry
of how coronavirus has passed from one
person to another what they do want to
know is like your your footage showed
when what's gonna happen for my birthday
and well I still be able to go my school
trips so we need to give them enough
information that they understand a
little bit about what is going on but
they don't need to know as much as we do
as adults right and the reality of the
situation is often when when schools are
closed oh and there the kids are not at
school they'd go to their grandparents
to be looked after how do we explain to
children that that's not happening this
time without sort of worrying them that
the grannies gonna die yes and by
explaining that this is an illness that
seems to particularly hit older people
and people at risk so we want to protect
granny and granddad from getting ill and
reassure them that granny granddad are
doing everything that they can to stay
safe and that you can stay in touch
through Skype or FaceTime or you can
even write letters to them and but that
we might not see them for a little while
if if your child asks well this does
that mean granddad's gonna die we need
to be very
honest with our children and not make
promises that we can't keep so you don't
want to say of course he won't because
you know we just don't know so you need
to say while we're doing everything we
can to keep grandad safe and chances are
he's gonna be absolutely fine and we
just need to let them know how much we
still think about him even if we can't
see him so it's a lot for children to
take in and children tend to take their
emotion from parents so if you are very
anxious as a parent chances are your
child's going to also feel very anxious
so you've got to try and stay very
logical and rational as much as possible
when you're with your children and don't
let them watch too much news don't let
them listen to the news too much either
just so that they only get the
information that they need nothing less
that is very clear thank you so much for
that dr. Anne Herod Rudkin from the
University of Southampton I'll turn now
to the world of sport which has also
been hit hard by the pandemic European
football's governing body UEFA has
confirmed that the Euro 2020 tournament
will be postponed until next year it's
also put all other men's and women's
competitions on hold
uf has been holding meetings with clubs
and member associations that today it
hopes at postponing Euro 2020 means
domestic leagues will be able to play
into May and June complete their seasons
and minimizing the financial impact
more from there Jonathan crane from DW
sport Oh welcome Jonathan so that's that
you wait for decision in a nutshell
what's behind it well I think they've
basically realized that hosting such a
tournament in the current climate is
totally unrealistic they've seen the
piling up of fixtures in the domestic
leagues they've said it's more important
to help domestically to try to finish
their season I think they also want to
ease the burden on the 12 countries that
were due to host this tournament they
will now get their chance in 2020 won
the tournament they're due to run from
the 11th of June to the 11th of July now
as we said you Ava's decision follow two
video conferences today one with clubs
and leagues the other with the 55 member
associations UEFA president Alexander
Chephren praised the Solidarity showed
by Obama because this was obviously no
easy decision now it's all going to be
about the detail you wafer has set up a
working group that will look at how the
football calendar is going to look going
forward and also assess the financial
consequences of Buster we're postponing
such a tournament so and so where does
it leave clubs and leagues around Europe
well primarily it does give them the
chance to finish the season we've seen
how the corona virus has caused all
major European leagues including the
Bundesliga to grind to a halt and that's
caused so much uncertainty will the
competitions be finished what will
happen with promotions and relegations
and what about players whose contracts
are due to expire yesterday we heard
from the head of the German Football
League Christians eyford and he talked
about how a football in Germany alone
employs 56,000 people so imagine all the
uncertainty for them millions hundreds
of millions of euros also at stake for
clubs and TV revenue now of course the
spawning a Euro 2020 does give a bit
more breathing space the domestic
leagues could play into May and June but
it all depends really on how the
coronavirus develops itself and that's
the big question mark and what about
some of the other competitions due to
take place well as we said at the top
are all UEFA competitions now and hold
on hold that includes the Champions
League and Europa League the copper
America which is the national
competition for South America that's
also been postponed for 2021 but of
course this is now causing a pileup of
tournaments as well the women's euros
would you to take place and
next year in London from July the 7th
talk now from member associations that
they will be moved to 2022 that's not
the only clash though the UEFA will be
competing with FIFA next year if FIFA
holds its club world cup / that's Jenni
in fan Tino's pet project so a lot of
discussions between organizations need
to take place one silver lining
potentially though the World Cup that
would normally take place in June July
2022 will take place in November in
Qatar because of the weather so that
does give some free time maybe in that
summer to play some of these tournaments
that have been postponed I think we need
a spreadsheet I think you do very
complicated all right Jonathan crane dad
DW sport thank you you're welcome